thank you for joining us here at noon
i'm hector mejia we start this thursday
afternoon with a covet update just into
our newsroom we've learned
nevada governor steve sisilak is
expected to hold a press conference
later this afternoon
at 2 p.m in fact to provide updates on
her covet response here in nevada
we will carry that live on air and
online meanwhile
dr anthony fauci says he believes the
u.s could start seeing
as many as 200 000 you covet cases a day
by the fall
to put that into perspective that number
was just ten
thousand daily a few weeks ago skyler
henry has the details from the white
house
[Applause]
health officials say they are concerned
about how quickly the delta variant is
spreading
there were some early preliminary
studies that suggest
that delta may potentially cause severe
disease
we continue to monitor this not just in
adults but also in children
that has prompted some state governors
to reinstitute protective policies
effective immediately all p12
schools and day cares in illinois must
follow the cdc guidance of universal
masking inside regardless of vaccine
status but florida
governor ron desantis has banned any
such mass mandate from schools in his
state
if you're coming after the rights of
parents in florida
i'm standing in your way i'm not going
to let you get away with it
even though it just set a new record for
covet hospitalizations during the
pandemic
over the past seven days florida and
texas
have accounted for about one-third of
new cases
and more than one-third of new
hospitalizations nationwide
the federal government is only issuing
guidelines for most
leaving policies up to the states but
the biden administration is taking steps
to
mandate coveted vaccines where it can
cbs news has confirmed defense secretary
lloyd austin plans to seek authorization
for mandatory covid vaccinations for all
active duty troops the delta variant has
certainly
affected us here in the military as it
has affected the rest of the country
and and when we have more to say about
the status of the vaccines will
certainly do that and the biden
administration is working on a plan to
require almost
all foreign visitors to be fully
vaccinated prior to entering the u.s
the rules will be phased in and will
apply to visitors coming from all
countries
schuyler henry cbs news the white house
all right new data from modernist says
its covet vaccine remains
93 percent effective even after six
months after getting the second dose
the company says it's also testing out a
potential cova 19 booster shot
as well as vaccines for the zika virus
hiv
and the flu they're still in the early
stages though
now to a quick look at our coveted
numbers nevada is reporting over
1100 new cases and 26 deaths the
statewide positivity rate sits at
15.7 percent meanwhile in clark county
the rate here
is a point higher at 16.7 percent
the majority of those new cases came
from clark county
unlv is offering testing and vaccines
today at the stan fulton building
they'll close
tomorrow and saturday and then reopen on
sunday
it'll open sundays through thursdays
from 5 30 pm to 10 30 at night
vaccines and covet tests will be
available on a first come
first served basis and more places to
get the coronavirus vaccine several
pop-up clinics around the valley have
plenty on hand today from 3 to 6 p.m you
can go to canarelli middle school
a second option you see there on your
screen is woodbury middle school open
until 2 p.m
and then this saturday fountain of hope
ame church will open from 7 30 a.m to 1
30 p.m no appointments are necessary for
that site
for a full list of vaccine clinics and
testing sites just head over to our
website eight news now
dot com